وعلى الرغم من الضجه التي خلفها تاييد
اوغامي اردوغان الا ان اختياره هذا كان
مرجحا فاغامي يطمح للحصول على منصب حكومي
كما صرح بذلك مرارا وبالتالي فان تاييده
لاردوغان صاحب الصداره في الجوله الاولى
يعطيه فرصا او فرد كما ان اوغان ينحدر
اصلا من حزب الحركه القوميه الموجوده في
التحالف الحاكم بالاساس
وفي هذا الخضم يبدو ان تعيد اوجان
لاردوغان لا يعني بان الاخيره سيستفيد من
جميع اصوات اوغان في الجوله الثانيه بهذا
الخصوص ذكرت صحيفه الامريكيه ان سنان
اوغان لا يملك اي جهاز حزبي لتعبئه مؤيديه
سيما بعد تفكك تحالف الاجداد الذي يمثله
مع نهايه الجوله الاولى كما ذكرت ان هناك
العديد من الناخبين الذين صوتوا لسنان
اوغان في الجوله الاولى لم يكونوا ضمن
مؤيديه في المقام الاول ولكنهم صوتوا له
اعتراضا على ترشح اردوغان وكلج دارولو وما
يعزز هذا الطرح هو استطلاع الاجره صحيفه
زمان التركيه والذي اظهر ان 1.25 من حوالي
الخمسه التي حصل عليها اوغام في الجوله
الاولى ستتجه الى اردوغان مقابل 1.8 فقط
ستتجه الى كلارلو ومن المتوقع ان يمتنع
نحو 2% عن المشاركه في الجوله الثانيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات